okay so now get it
direct is i have that same body lock i
do the body lock throw the body lock
throw
it's not that i hit him
and he takes a kimmy or you know i'm not
knocking him down
and uh i'm also not turning him that
wouldn't be direct so i don't come
backwards
and then turn him not i'm not doing that
i just find the wedge
his body is getting tilted so i'll do it
on his
on his body here so you can see his body
is getting tilted
so from here then i'm going to wedge his
body
with edemi so wedge
so same thing here
so my hand never goes backwards
my hand goes forward forward
and i'm not knocking him just wedging
him
what you'll see different is my hands
going backwards
then he bends back
and then on the the smacking one he
stops poke he stops going forward
but on this one you'll see that he keeps
coming around he gets really deep
really deep
up
now and not hit
oh that guy's too big attack his body
wedge make him keep coming forward
[Music]
this technique is exposing uh
that you're not uh throwing the person
until you yawn their head here
[Music]
when you see my head connect or my hand
on his head i'm following his head i'm
not pushing his head down
okay his his body already turned
and i'm staying with an ik adhesion on
his head
so he's already falling and i'm staying
with his head
not so the same thing here
when you go into this technique you're
not trying to shove the guy but it's too
much mass
so i'm not shoving him it's just going
in my way
this wedging
wedging
my arm's going down his butt i'm just
staying with his body
i'm not sitting here i'm not doing that
just wedgies okay
try it again